deutschland brennt und zwar tatsächlich
im wahrsten sinne des wortes vor hitze
das hier sind nicht bilder aus spanien
oder griechenland bilder aus england
oder frankreich wie sie die letzten tage
vielleicht gesehen haben das hier ist
die a 44 bei kasse also nicht nur heißen
sommertemperaturen sondern auch immer
wieder brände hier bei uns in
deutschland diese hitzerekorde sind
nicht nur für die natur sondern auch für
uns menschen
brandgefährlich flächendeckende hitze
temperaturen über 40 grad waldbrände
europa geht und dann in der nacht
plötzlich gewitter hagel starkregen
alles folgen des klimawandels donner
orkanböen zerstörung in der nacht ist
die feuerwehr in süddeutschland im
dauereinsatz 30 einsatzkräfte kämpfen
hier gegen die gewalt der natur extreme
windböen wie sie sehen fegen durch die
nacht bäume knicken wie streichhölzer
baustellen fallen wie kartenhäuser in
sich zusammen es herrscht tatsächlich
das totale chaos ein ähnliches bild auch
in baden württemberg ein blitzeinschlag
setzt hier eine schaaf führte in brand
die einsatzkräfte können das feuer noch
rechtzeitig löschen retten zwei schafe
insgesamt sind hier sechs fahrzeuge und
insgesamt 40 mann im einsatz